[Musique]
petits enfants ce reportage s'adressent
spécialement à vue parce que nous venons
de retrouver dans le morvan où il se
cache le père et la mère fouettard pour
les enfants dites moi où est ce qu'il y
à malam arrache la ville avec les martin
oui oui obama comment il est
alors madame c'est vous qui fabrique et
les martinez pour les petits enfants et
vous en fabriquer beaucoup comme ça
avant qu est ce qui vous vous rendez
compte madame des rivières de larmes que
vous faites couler chez tous les dix ans
franck france et d'ailleurs je ne sais
pas moi on peut-être pas ça fait
peut-être pas c'est tout vous avez des
petits enfants oui est intéressant mais
qu'est ce qu'ils en disent eh ben ils
coulent pas tellement près non plus
il ya encore beaucoup de parents qui se
servent de martin est à votre avis la
réponse oui qui en a pas mal parce qu'on
n'en voit pas mal alors je pense qu'ils
s'aiment vous entendrez beaucoup oui à
qui des grossistes m j'ai des régions
lüthi enfants sont moins sage que dans
tes droits
je suppose sur paris en avons beaucoup
dans beaucoup aussi
ça veut pas dire qu'ailleurs ils sont
très gentils mais certainement pas mais
enfin vous voyez c'est surtout les
régions où les plus demandés
[Musique]
au point de vue technique un bon martin
et qu'est ce que c'est c'est un bon
manche en bois bien solide auquel on
ajoute des belles manières assez long
qui épouse la forme des petites fessées
et bien petits enfants vous avez vu
maintenant à vous de choisir où vous
êtes sages ou bien alors
[Musique]
ah oui le mappy member